-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody!
You're here.
You made it.
Thank you for watching.
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, we are right in the middle
of the holiday season.
Are you excited?
[ Cheers and applause ]
According to a survey,
during the holidays,
most dog owners
buy a gift for their pet.
Yeah.
And then there's the people
that are too lazy to shop
and just give their dog cash.
[ Laughter ]
Buying a gift for a dog
is stressful.
I mean, seriously,
there's nothing more depressing
than watching your dog
open a present
then fake wagging his tail.
[ Laughter ]
You go, "Okay.
He didn't like it. Okay."
Let's get to some news.
Today, President Biden
hosted a ceremony
on the South Lawn
to sign a bill that mandates
federal recognition
for same-sex marriages.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
When he heard,
Mike Pence was like,
"Barkeep, give me a shot
of whole milk."
[ Laughter ]
"Just leave the whole carton."
Yeah, the bill protects
all marriages.
Unless you're
one of those couples
who feed each other in public.
Then you're on your own.
[ Laughter ]
I read that Ivanka Trump
and Jared Kushner
cut ties
with former president Trump
because he's "losing value"
and they don't need him anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's not even upset.
He's like, "The student
has become the master."
[ Laughter ]
Things are so rough
in the Trump family,
even the royal family's like,
"Yikes."
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this today?
A bipartisan group of lawmakers
announced a bill
that would ban TikTok
in the U.S.
-[ Person whistles ]
[ Laughter ]
Right now, gen Z is like,
"We ride at dawn."
[ Laughter ]
Critics of TikTok worry that the
app is giving American secrets
to the Chinese government.
Yeah, pretty scary.
Apparently, China has already
mastered the "Wednesday" dance.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, get this,
a TikTok-famous plastic surgeon
just had her
medical license suspended
after she was accused
of botched surgeries.
See, that's why I only use
YouTube-famous plastic surgeons.
[ Laughter ]
When asked for a comment,
she said,
"Look, I don't see them
as botched surgeries.
I look at them as cool filters."
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, New York City
is experiencing high levels
of COVID, flu, and RSV
in what health officials
are calling a "tridemic."
And Pfizer is promoting
a new booster shot
to protect against it.
Check this out.
-As cases continue to rise,
experts recommend
getting the latest boosters
for COVID, the flu, and RSV.
But as the holidays approach,
we might not all have time
for multiple appointments.
That's why we're introducing
The Destroyer.
Just one quick jab,
and you're protected from...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow, indeed!
-Wow!
Multiple injections.
Oh, my goodness.
Firecrotch, unbelievable.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I want to say
happy birthday to Bob Barker
who just turned 99!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you, Bob.
You could tell he hosted
"The Price is Right"
'cause that's the closest
you can come to 100
without going over.
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears,
Uber Eats released
its annual Cravings Report,
which revealed
the hottest
food-ordering trends of 2022.
And the trends
were pretty interesting.
For example,
more people requested
celery juice on Wednesdays.
-Oh. Man, see, I always ordered
celery juice on Wednesday.
-Yeah. On Friday, there's
a spike in cannoli orders.
-Wow! I get cannolis, you know,
every Friday, too.
That's crazy.
-Yeah, well, apparently, orders
of ranch dressing went way down.
-Ha! See, I didn't order
any ranch this year.
[ Laughter ]
-And the big drink craze
was a negroni sbagliato.
-Sbagliato, you say.
Those are good.
The only thing better
is a margarita.
It goes great with a steak.
[ Laughter ]
-It makes sense.
I mean, the most frequently
paired food/drink combo
was steak and margarita.
-Huh.
[ Ominous music plays ]
Really?
W-What about Saturdays?
I got to be the only one
who orders tater tots
and says to hold the --
-Sour cream.
[ Laughter ]
Dammit.
-W-What?
What's wrong, Tariq?
-No, it -- it can't be.
-What?
W-- What is it?
-No way, n-not me.
-Say it.
What is it, Tariq?
[ Dramatic music crescendos ]
-I think I might be
a basic bitch.
[ Laughter ]
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause continues ]
-Or you're a trendsetter.
-Damn right I am!
♪ You're the best around ♪
♪ Nothing's gonna ever
keep you down ♪
♪ You're the best around ♪
-Tariq Trotter, everyone.
Tariq Trotter.
Wow, I was worried.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was worried.
Whew!
I was worried for a second.
Guys, I heard about --
a new study found that people
who wake up with an alarm clock
are more tired than people
who wake up naturally.
Another reason people who use
an alarm clock are tired --
they have jobs.
[ Laughter ]
This is wild.
An Olive Garden manager
was fired
after sending the staff
an aggressive warning
about missing work.
Listen to this.
-The message from
an Olive Garden manager
in Kansas to employees.
[ Laughter ]
-Good news, though --
today, she was hired to be
the head of H.R. at Twitter.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Good news.
Yeah, it all works out.
And finally,
we have exactly four shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved "Tonight Show"
tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ 4 days left ♪
-That's right! Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a boom-bastic Christmas sweater
from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
Since there are four shows left,
let's open door number 4.
-Let's do it.
[ Drumroll ]
-Yep.
Go for it.
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Can we dim the lights?
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not bad.
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants this sweater?
It's a good one!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who's sitting at 430?!
Yeah!
Come on, bud!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hey!
Come on over!
You're over there.
Nice to see you, brother.
Go over there.
Hey, what is your name,
and where are you from?
-Giovanni.
Cincinnati, Ohio.
-Hey, that's what I'm talking
about -- Cincinnati, Ohio!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I've been to Cincinnati
when it's cold.
And, man, oh, man,
nothing like having
the pasta with chili on it,
right?
-Skyline.
-Yeah, Skyline, exactly.
And I go there,
and I have to wear a sweater
'cause it's so cold.
Do you have a sweater like this?
-I do not.
-Yeah.
Now you do.
Would you like to try it on
for everyone?
-I would love to.
-Here you go, bud.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This will be perfect.
Go to Skyline -- look at this.
Wow.
Yep.
Oh, my gosh, it's subtle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's so good.
It looks good.
Look at you.
Come on, look at him.
That's what
I'm talking about, man.
It looks great.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations.
Give it up
for our winner right there.
Round of applause.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.
She'll take you
to your seat over there.
Thank you.
♪♪
Oh, that's awesome.
Fantastic.
Hey, you know what?
You know what?
I'm in the giving spirit.
[ Cheers ]
I mean, why -- why does
just one person get a gift?
Why can't everyone
in the audience get a gift?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
It's time for "Tonight Show
Stocking Stuffers"!
Here we go!
-♪ It's the Tonight Show ♪
-♪ Stocking Stuffers ♪
♪ Stocking Stuffers ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm gonna need some help
on this giveaway.
She is the host of the hit show
"The Drew Barrymore Show."
Ladies and gentlemen,
Drew Barrymore!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi, guys!
-Oh! Oh, la la!
[ Both laugh ]
Oh, look at -- oh, my.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is --
-Oh, look at everybody!
-Come on, they love you.
Drew!
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Drew, thank you so much.
-Hi!
-Thank you so much
for being here.
-Oh, you all look so lovely!
-They look good, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're happy you're here.
-Oh, I'm so happy
to see you guys.
Happy holidays!
-Happy holidays, that's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Drew, thank you for being here.
Thank you for being here.
-Of course, Jimmy.
-Yes.
We are about to give them
a stocking stuffer tonight.
-Well, I actually hope that
your stocking is very large
and capable of being stuffed
with the item that I have.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Wow!
♪♪
I-I-I understand.
That's unbelievable.
Wow.
-I'm just saying it might be
bigger than a stocking.
-Okay, all right.
Hey.
Everyone in tonight's
studio audience
is going home with this tonight.
So no need
to check under your seat.
Everyone's getting it.
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone is getting it.
-Tonight, you're all
going home with...
a new beautiful
6-quart digital air fryer!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right, Jimmy and Drew!
The beautiful 6-quart
digital air fryer
by Drew Barrymore
is sold exclusively at Walmart
and combines high performance
with an elegant design
that looks beautiful
on your kitchen counter.
Back to you, Jimmy and Drew.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My thanks to Drew Barrymore!
Check your local listings for
"The Drew Barrymore Show"!
We love you, come on.
Mwah!
We'll be right back with more of
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Come on back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪